I asked Brad about the kiss he said that
it was improvised but it was all good
yeah we all established our boundaries
before making this movie because it's a
you know a movie that really pushes
boundaries in a lot of ways so yeah I
need to know did you drop the Barbie
Trail are you the one who leaked the
Barbie trailer I didn't no but uh you'll
see it tomorrow in all its Glory
everybody's excited about that there was
so much reaction were you surprised
about how people just went crazy with
that little slip
uh yeah it feels like anything that
happens gets a huge reaction for Bobby
so it's exciting I also want to ask you
about the DC shakeup because now Lady
Gaga is going to be playing Harley Quinn
what do you think about that because
it's going to be a musical
movie I think she's going to do an
amazing job I'm so excited it's all I
could have ever hoped for Harley was
that she would become one of those
characters that kind of like Batman or
Hamlet gets handed from character to you
know actor to actor everyone gets a go
at playing them so I feel like it's just
credit to her as a character that you
know people want to see her in multiple
iterations I'm excited this movie is
Grand and glamorous how were you going
to match that tonight and you surely did
what are you wearing I'm wearing an Elia
dress and um yeah it's it's reminiscent
of uh you know the outfit I'm wearing in
this it's kind of like that outfit was
inspired by her throwing in a scarf and
tonight it's like the winter version of
that I think
foreign